hi I'm Erik Bosse and the recent
Avengers endgame trailer packed an
impossible amount of cryptic detail into
30 seconds it was really the Chipotle
burrito of movie trailers except
digesting this one makes you sick up
here these 30 seconds were so packed
that after spending 20 minutes or so
breaking it all down there were actually
two more big details that I didn't cover
for the many of you tweeted me about
these I've heard you loud and clear so
loud it's so clear really these could be
the most critical clues yet as we
theorized how Avengers in game will
change the game spoiler warning Casey
and I predicted Mir and they're ruining
life okay the first detail involves this
shot at the end of the recent trailer
showing some of the Avengers marching
across Avengers HQ cap Thor Black Widow
rocket ant-man Rhodey and banner I
already pointed out how this shot is
peculiar because the first trailer we
saw for Avengers in game in December
showed us the exact same shot except
with the room empty of people maybe the
director shot multiple versions of the
scene to have extra footage and they're
still editing all the effects as we've
seen before with trailers and promo
footage or maybe these two versions were
before-and-after versions of the same
shot showing the Avengers blipping out
of this reality or going back in time
you can watch my full breakdown for more
of a discussion on that but here I want
to point out one more major discrepancy
look at the building outside in the
background in the new shot with all the
Avengers in it you can see the Avengers
a logo on side of the building but back
in the December footage that logo is
missing oh my god okay I got three
theories for what this could mean one we
could just chalk this up to the most
logical explanation that the first shot
was unfinished footage that the
filmmakers used for marketing like how
we often see alternate footage and
trailers that never make it into the
final version of the movie look guys a
big-budget films all kinds of details
and shots are added and changed in
post-production through visual effects
not just big explosions or crazy CGI
characters they'll digitally swap out
random TV screens license plates trees
on the horizon the director gets annoyed
with overly reflective sunglasses
directors like David Fincher will
agonize over tiny details of the
backgrounds of his shots digitally
painting over them in ways that we would
never notice or care about so yeah I
could totally see the Avengers crew not
bothering to build a big a logo and
installing it on the side of a building
and instead just using VFX to
painted over in post and what we saw in
December was maybe just before the VFX
artists had a chance to do that but what
if for people who don't think logically
well let's assume that there was some
truth to my earlier theory that the old
and new shots with and without Avengers
were actually before-and-after shots at
the same moment in which the Avengers
faded away from this timeline leaving an
empty room if that's true this missing
logo could be evidence of time travel
like remember before this facility in
upstate New York became Avengers HQ it
was actually an old stark warehouse
according to Hank Pym and ant-man
such a warehouse would not have any
Avengers a on the side that logo didn't
even exist until after the Battle of New
York when Loki's attack damaged stark
tower in such a way that only the a was
left on the side of the building
reflecting its new home as Avengers
Tower so maybe this empty room is
showing the facility back in the past
long before the Avengers came together
the avengers could be traveling back in
time to that moment perhaps that's why
that video feed that cap and natasha saw
of Scott Lang and the first trailer said
archive up there in the corner like
maybe Scott could have slipped into one
of those time vortexes in the quantum
realm traveled to Avengers HQ back when
it was still a stark warehouse no logo
as Hank Pym once told him it would be my
third theory for this is similar but
instead of back in time the Avengers
could be hopping horizontally into a
parallel timeline within the multiverse
like instead of an earlier period before
the Avengers existed this could be a
timeline in which the Avengers never
existed like maybe they never came
together during Loki's attack and Nick
Fury's whole Avengers initiative failed
and this time when he trusted someone he
lost sway more than an eye look whether
or not this missing a logo is a
bombshell clue or just yet to be added
visual effect it's worth mentioning how
much Past Marvel films have focused on
this logo there was that iconic shot
from the first Avengers movie and
spider-man homecoming ended with Peter
Parker heroically framed with it in the
state of this a symbol and Avengers
endgame could be used as a visual
barometer for the hero's progress during
their timeline Medlin the way in Back to
the Future Marty McFly used a photo of
him with his siblings to see if he still
existed in the future okay there's one
more amazing diesel that you might have
missed in the in-game trailer but before
we get to that this video was sponsored
by expressvpn a VPN allows you to browse
the internet with privacy without things
like ad companies or hackers bite where
any of these things tracking their data
and secretly filtering your Internet
experience Express maybe in masks your
IP address to make sure that you aren't
being monitored so that you can have
that peace of mind you can live life
knowing no one's staring a peeping at
you or tracking you expressvpn is the
fastest VPN on the market the number one
VPN service rated by tech radar and if
you end up in a different country at any
point you might not be able to access
everything on Netflix or YouTube other
streaming services but thanks to express
VPN you can avoid these weird
restrictions you can just watch
everything that you would want to watch
normally the way the Internet should be
wherever you are
Express VPN allows you to securely
stream or download content from anywhere
anytime and it's less than seven dollars
a month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee take back your internet
privacy today and find out how you can
get three months free by clicking on the
link in the description box expressvpn
comm slash new rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash new
rockstars for three months free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn comm
slash new rockstars to learn more take
back your privacy today ok the second
major detail from this endgame trailer
overall it features one simple line of
dialogue some people move on but not us
not us and the entity makes it seem like
this is all coming from Captain America
Steve Rogers but listening closely there
are definitely differences in different
parts of this audio like it sounds like
it could be multiple voices the first
words some people
sounds like Tony's start some people
whereas the words but not us
sounds more like half - in my trailer
breakdown I compared this cap audio to
the echoed not us at the end of the
trailer suggesting that maybe we might
see multiple versions of cap an end game
a past and a present cap or maybe a
reality a cap a reality B cap just go
watch a video but let's listen to this
again specifically the middle part of
the audio move on it sounds like a third
character some people move on
doesn't that sound a bit like Thanos
josh brolin the hardest choices are the
strongest we'll move on today I lost
more than you can know
move on move on Wow who decide if the
Avengers got their dog pile on rolling
strategy from The Goonies oh no maybe
I've just listened this too many times
really now it kind of sounds like Thanos
is saying Annie but I could imagine some
scene in game in which they a nose tells
the heroes you have to move on the snap
is done kill me all you want I don't
care but sooner or later you have to an
Avengers in game I predict these three
characters stark cap Thanos will be the
three at the heart of the showdown maybe
this trailer stitching together pieces
of their dialogue could reflect these
three characters coming together on one
team
remember cabin stark still haven't made
up since Civil War and both of them
really hate pianos maybe endgame will
feature a coming to terms among these
three rivals
danos could realize his snap really
didn't make anything better and the
three of them could work together to
undo this costly mistake oh no I want to
know from you which of these three
characters do you think will surprise us
the most in avengers endgame common down
below with your thoughts follow me on
twitter and instagram @ ee vas and
subscribe to this channel and subscribe
to our podcast wherever you listen to
podcasts thank you for watching and hey
sapote late no hard feelings I love your
food
I'd eat it every day if I could just
give me a free food you're pulling come
on I'll go NASCAR and I'll cover this
whole freaking body which of wooly logos
might have to come on let's do this
[Music]